>> A FALIC PLASTY IS BASICALLY
TO CREATE A PENIS.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
CHRIS RUFO SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
MANHATTAN INSTITUTE.
CHRIS THEY'RE THREATENING AND
DEFAMING PEOPLE LIKE YOU, THEY
DIDN'T USE YOUR NAME, BUT THIS
IS REALLY NOW SOVIET STYLE
OPERATION HERE WITH WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH JUST A DEBATE ABOUT A
VERY CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND, I MEAN, HERE ARE THE BASIC
FACTS.
WE KNOW FROM THE MEDICAL
LITERATURE THAT DOCTORS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE PERFORMING
DOUBLE MAST HE CAN DOMES AND
PINHE CAN DOMES AND CREATING AN
ARTIFICIAL VA GINA FOR MINORS
UNDER THE AGE OF 18 AND SIMPLY
BY POINTING THIS OUT THERE'S A
FURIOUS REACTION.
THEY'RE TRYING TO MOBILIZE THE
FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND MOBILE ICE THE ENTIRE
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
APPARATUS TO SENSOR JOURNALISTS
DEPLATFORM JOURNALISTS AND THEY
SAY SPECIFICALLY INVESTIGATE AND
FROM JOURNALISTS.
THIS IS A RECKLESS MOVE DESIGNED
TO CRIMINAL ICE DECENT AND
PROTECT THESE REALLY AWFUL AND
HORRIFIC RADICAL SURGERIES AND
EXPERIMENTS THEY'RE PERFORMING
ON MINORS.
>> Laura: I BELIEVE THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CAME UP WITH THE
FRONTAL LA BOT MY SURGERY DIDN'T
THAT PERSON WIN THE NOBEL PRIZE
FOR MEDICINE, WASN'T THAT 1947?
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU GET THE FEELING THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE NEW FRONTAL LA
BOT MY AT SOME POINT THE WAY
THIS IS GOING.
BUT THE IDEA THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PROCEED WITHOUT ANY
CRITICISM, WITHOUT ANY
EXAMINATION OF THEIR TACTICS AND
THEIR CONCLUSIONS IS JUST
LUDICROUS ON EVERY LEVEL.
AND IT'S UP TO EVERY JOURNALIST,
I DON'T KNOW CARE WHAT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IS, TO STAND UP FOR
INQUIRY AND FRANKLY AGGRESSIVE
INQUIRY WHEN IT COMES TO
CHILDREN'S PERMANENT SURGERY
THAT WILL CHANGE THEIR LIVES
FOREVER.
CHILDREN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I'D LIKE TO DELIVER A
MESSAGE DIRECTLY TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND.
YOU CAN INTIMIDATE US AND
THREATEN US.
YOU CAN MOBILE ICE THE FBI
AGAINST US.
YOU CAN EVEN DRAG US OUT OF OUR
HOMES IN A PREDAWN RAID.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO STOP
REPORTING ON RADICAL GENDER IN
SCHOOLS AND SURGERIES ON MINORS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO STOP UNTIL
WE'VE TAKEN THIS RADICAL
IDEOLOGY OUT HAVE OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO TO
STOP US, THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY ARE COMING AND WON'T
STOP UNTIL YOU'RE FINISHED.
>> Laura: I THINK A LOT OF THE
NEW IMMIGRANTS COMING INTO T